well in the middle of the latest LeBron
there is LeBron James Caan Jersey
barstool sports is now selling this
t-shirt chairman James Dave Portnoy
founded barstool now an international
brand not beholding to China and he
joins us tonight
you're not bold to China are you I'm
just I'm guessing this I'm not beholding
to China talk about I'm gonna be honest
I'm one of the few honest guys if they
guaranteed me like 2 billion people
would bike t-shirts I may fall in line
like everybody else I can't say we're
doing that would you admit it as you did
it though well that's the thing that's
what drives me insane with all these
people you have to admit it if they said
hey we're gonna have a billion people by
teachers I'll go retire in our island
I'll put my hand up and be like hey hey
put money in my pocket I don't agree
with what they're doing that's what
drives me insane it's the hypocrisy like
LeBron what are you talking with just a
minute it's your it's you you won right
billionaire that's it that and this
story but it is a little much to lecture
the rest of us in this country about our
failings while at the same time refusing
to acknowledge that the Chinese
government which is pretty disgusting I
mean really has done anything wrong ever
like why do that why don't we quiet
about all politics listen I don't like
LeBron James I think he's a hypocrite
and I've always said that when I saw
what he tweeted out I ran to my computer
I couldn't believe he said it just keep
your mouth shut how tone-deaf do you
have to be it is insane when you put the
tweets that he has had in his past next
to each other one second he says you
can't be silent doesn't matter about
money contracts whatever basic human
rights and then he says the exact
opposite you can't talk some issues is
gonna be quiet like it this moment has
well I saw through him the whole time
he's a hypocrite he'll say you know
people go to LA they don't care about
basketball that's why they look he's a
hypocrite his kid he'll say stavos kid
he doesn't like too much pressure yet he
named him LeBron James jr. I mean
everything that says he's hypocritical
this may be the issue where people
finally wake up because like what you've
said it doesn't matter what side of the
aisle on it doesn't matter everybody
agrees this is about basic human decency
and you care more about your money and
becoming a billionaire that's it
so we're piling on LeBron James and I
think it's obvious he deserves it but
what about his handler
at Nike I mean clearly he's taking
orders from them now here's what I think
happens with LeBron James I don't think
he's ever been told no in his life so
when he tweeted that out
he said hey King hey King you know the
haters don't like this you may want to
just they're haters though they'll never
tell me did anything wrong it's like
when you're a heavyweight champ in the
world that was like champ champ champ
they talked to LeBron like is it God
he's never been told he's wrong and I
guarantee you they phrased this like
we're the crazy ones like King don't
worry about it King some people just
getting a little ruffled we may have to
backtrack I guarantee he has a huge
pseudo apology still coming he has to
but it's fake everything about him is
fake he just showed his true colors how
can anybody with everything going on he
blames it on daryl morey this is real
issues this is real human rights
violations going on and he's tweeting
well you made me uncomfortable I didn't
get a good night's sleep it's crazy
it's crazy so most people as you pointed
out are selling t-shirts in China you're
selling t-shirts against China how many
of you sold a lot these have cut well
Donald Trump jr. retweeted this the
second we put the shirt on sales so that
certainly helped he's becoming like a
bar stool superfan which is great so
we've so low I think we're about 3,000
of these we've sold pretty quickly and
by the way just in the again I'm gonna
be fair we actually had an anti China
impro China t-shirt in the same blog
blue states red states they both buy
shirts communist Democrats they both buy
shirts will sell me who's ever Buy in
Tucker and you're honest about it with
the last honest man in digital media
Dave Portnoy barstool great see tonight
thank you you too